[music playing]
NARRATOR: Despite the fact that
it is not open to the public,
ancient astronaut
theorist Giorgio Tsoukalos
asked Nick Pope to
take him to the CCC
for a firsthand look
at the installation.
GIORGIO TSOUKALOS: All right.
Good luck.
Thank you very much.
NARRATOR: As a former employee
of the Ministry of Defense,
Nick did not feel it
was appropriate for him
to approach the facility
himself without clearance.
- I'll see you later, Nick.
- Yes.
Take care.
[door closes]
[music playing]
GIORGIO TSOUKALOS: Here we are.
The CCC.
[music playing]
The lights are on.
And just like Nick explained,
it's got a barbed wire.
It is fenced down.
Impenetrable.
NARRATOR: According to the
British Ministry of Defense,
the CCC is simply
a data processing
center for the Royal Navy.
But if true, why is
it so heavily guarded?
Clearly it's an
access to what seems
to be an underground system.
And if the stories that
Nick told me are true,
then underneath our feet
is a vast system of tunnels
and underground facilities.
[first responder sirens wailing]
NARRATOR: Within minutes
of Giorgio's arrival
at the security
gate, the crew is
met by a military police unit.
GIORGIO TSOUKALOS: Can you tell
me anything about this place?
NARRATOR: Unfortunately,
the situation
ends with filming being halted.
GIORGIO TSOUKALOS:
Well, we're only
trying to find out the truth.
NARRATOR: But why?
What is it that's so top secret
that Giorgio and his camera
crew are not even allowed
to film the entrance
from public property?
[music playing]
So it was exactly
how you said.
Fortification,
barbed wire fence.
I had about five minutes and
then a police car showed up.
And said, well, I think
it's time for you to leave.
So I think you did exactly
the right thing to get
out there while you could.
But you know that A,
it is operational,
and B, it's obviously important.
They send the
security people out.
I guarantee you,
they had eyes on you
from the moment you started.
NARRATOR: Could this
seemingly innocuous building,
and the underground facilities
it lead to, be continuing
the extraterrestrial
investigations that
were previously carried
out at Rudloe Manor?
Ancient astronaut
theorists say yes.
And suggest that they are not
only looking into UFO reports,
but mysterious
phenomenon that has
been happening in the
county of Wiltshire
for thousands of years.
[music playing]
- I think this is it right here.
- Yes.
Here we are.
GIORGIO TSOUKALOS: Great.
NARRATOR: Author and
historian Andrew Collins
has lived in or near
Wiltshire for most of his life
and has investigated the
many strange happenings
associated with the area.
- How are you?
- All right.
- You good?
Yeah, you?
NARRATOR: Giorgio
and Nick arrange
to meet with him to discuss
why the Ministry of Defense
might have chosen this
location to be the headquarters
of their UFO investigations.
You're looking at the dead
center of weird activity
in the whole of Great Britain.
We've got UFOs.
We've got crop circles.
We've got the most intensive
amount of prehistoric sites.
Ancient mounds.
Barrows.
Plus, we have, obviously, the
strange activity that surrounds
places like Rudloe
Manor and Corsham,
as a whole, where we are today.
NICK POPE: : Absolutely.
And some of these sites, I
don't think people realize,
but they are older than
the Egyptian pyramids.
Absolutely.
We've got here Stonehenge
and Avebury itself.
Most people think
that these sites
go back 4,500 to 5,000 years.
But they, in fact, go back
at least 10,000 years.
I lived in the
center of Avebury,
which is the largest
stone circle complex
in the whole of the world.
UFOs have been seen in the
vicinity of the stones there.
Sometimes they have
been seen to actually
come in to the circle and land.
Other times, they have
manifested into strange shapes,
figures, things like that.
[music playing]
All around the
country, there are
certain areas
where UFOs manifest
more than anywhere else.
They're called window areas.
And I believe that the area
around Stonehenge and Avebury
is exactly one of
those window areas.